se sabe hasta ahora y cuál ha sido la
postura de los británicos frente a lo
que está pasando en el país vecino
francia aquí en el reino unido se ha
vivido una jornada electoral de mucha
normalidad de mucha tranquilidad para la
que se habilitaron 59 puntos de votación
especialmente 6 en londres otros en
escocia en irlanda del norte y en otras
ciudades de inglaterra esto para
responder a las críticas de las
elecciones de 2017 cuando se hablaba de
muchos problemas logísticos y demoras de
hasta tres horas de fila para poder
votar pero hoy por el contrario se ha
hablado de un proceso mucho más
organizado y muy rápido en total aquí en
el reino unido 117 mil ciudadanos
franceses están habilitados para votar
para de un total de 136 mil registrados
en el reino unido- seguramente las
próximas horas sabremos qué porcentaje
de estos 117 mil ciudadanos franceses
votaron aquí en estos 59 puntos de
votación en el reino unido aunque
también se estima que este país vive en
al menos 300.000 ciudadanos franceses
siendo londres especialmente uno de los
lugares favoritos y es considerada una
de las capitales del mundo con más
porcentaje de ciudadanos franceses
entretanto aquí en el reino unido- los
medios británicos abren sus informativos
con la noticia de la primera vuelta
presidencial en francia por los efectos
que esto puede tener para las relaciones
entre francia y el reino unido-